[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon.
Thank you Sophia for
this wonderful generous
introduction.
And thanks to all of you for
coming on this beautiful day.
And I don't think that anything
can beat spring colors.
Especially not fluorescence.
Microscopy will come to
that at the end of my talk.
And so far I just
start at the beginning.
In the 18th century,
nothing much
happened from the point of
view of the microscopist.
This was for you Bob.
The 17th century had seen the
invention of the microscope,
and for the first
time given access
to a miraculous world
previously unimaginable.
The 19th century lay
still ahead in the future.
And with the advancement
of microscopic technology,
it would bring the pathbreaking
discovery, for example,
of cells and pathogens.
Sandwiched-- so to speak--
between miracle and discovery,
18th century microscopy was
left with meer curiosity.
Curiosity we argue is
an interesting thing.
So I want to make
you start thinking
about biological emotion,
because it's my suspicion--
forgive me-- that you have
rarely done so with discussing
a case from the 18th century.
As you will see, the
case suits both meanings
of the word curiosity,
referring on the one hand
to our desire to know
and to learn something,
and on the other hand to a
strange and unusual object
or fact in itself.
So in the second half
of the 18th century,
a number of
microscopy books were
published in the German town
of Nuremburg-- which was then
at that time,
together with London,
the European Center for
scientific engraving
illustrated books, and
illumination of copper plates
and engravings.
And among those books
of Martin Frobenius
Ledermuller's
Microscopic Amusements.
And here.
This is the cover of the book.
The amusements are
accompanied by 100
delicate hand-colored engravings
of microscopic objects.
And in those plates,
nature is presented
in beautiful symmetry,
order, and ornamental design.
And you can see some of
the macroscopic objects
under investigation
that were in the book.
The amusements--
the microscope which
was used to make
these representations,
however, was not an
ordinary microscope,
but a solar microscope.
And a solar microscope
is an instrument
that is at the same time
a magnifying, as well
as, projecting device.
With the help of the
sunlight, the image
of the macroscopic
object is either
a transparent or
a liquid one, is
projected onto the wall
of a darkened room.
And here you can see one
of those instrument that
is at the Collection of
Historical Instruments.
And lucky enough
when I came here
at the beginning of
the academic year,
there was the exhibition
at the Harvard Art
Museum of the
Philosophy Chamber,
where they had two
of those projections.
The effect that you
can see here easily,
is that the minutest and
most delicate objects
are magnified to room size,
and thereby directly enter
the space of the spectator,
whereas, as you know maybe
from biology lessons,
in classical microscopy,
it is the instrument that is
between the microscopic world
of the observer, and
the microscopic one
under the tiny cover slip.
So solar microscopes
were widespread
in the Enlightenment.
They were part of what was
then seen as an artful science,
as part of the educated pastime
of the gentleman scientist.
And it was part of the
social activity of amateurs.
And demonstrations
with a solar microscope
were public demonstrations of
scientific, and in this case,
microscopic knowledge.
They were performances.
And I am interested in
a particular question.
What exactly was being
performed with the help
of those instruments?
We already know that one thing
was size, according to this.
And here we see the skin of
a finger, with all its lines,
pores, cracks,
and fine fissures.
Under the solar
microscope, however, we
see something else as well.
We can see you
projected onto the wall
the evaporation of the
hands like, I quote,
"a dense smoke rising
from the fingers."
So the copper plates-- that we
have preserved in this book--
meticulously capture the
structure of the skin.
But it's liveliness, it's
breathing, escapes them.
You might consider this
lack of vividness excusable.
After all it's a finger,
and you usually I guess
don't think of your fingers
as respiratory organs
in the first place.
But insects may
change your view.
Here you can see that's
an iconic depiction
of Robert Hooke's flea
from his micrography
in the 17th century.
And that might be the
most widespread image
of a microscopic object in
the 17th and 18th century.
And you'll easily see that this
depiction from Ledermuller's
book 100 years later is almost
identical in its structure.
So seeing an insect enlarged
too extravagant size
is indeed only one thing.
Seeing it move, however,
is quite another.
In his story Master
Flea E.T.A. Hoffman--
the novelist-- beautifully
captures the sensation
of insects moving in life-size
in a darkened room with
a spectator in the
midst of it I quote--
and I have the German
quote for those
that want to read the German,
because it's very vivid--
"The door of the hall
flew open violently,
and in frantic throng the
people plunged toward him, death
pale horror on their faces.
A glance into the hall revealed
at once two young peoples
the reason for this
frightful horror.
Inside everything was alive.
A revolting confusion of
the most loathsome creatures
filled the entire room.
The race of plant
lies, beetles, spiders,
slime worms magnified
to excessive size, where
extending their
proboscises, walking
about on tall, hairy
legs, and hideous antlions
were seizing and squashing
with their jagged claws,
that connects with
their long wings.
Never had [INAUDIBLE] held
anything more-- beheld anything
more revolting."
So in Hoffman's story,
magnification and movement
combined are a source of horror.
What the solar
microscope unveiled
was not the world
we have seen before,
a word of order and ornament,
but of utter disorder
of insects battling
fiercely, moving
erratically, a monstrous
mixture of the unknown.
Microscopic movement gave
reason for literary fiction.
Making sense of it in real
life was an equally imaginative
task.
And here you see the copper
plate of a single insect--
a water beetle-- or [INAUDIBLE]
as it is named in the book.
And this is actually a very
typical representation.
In the lower parts you
see anatomical details,
and in the upper part
the whole animal.
They are all magnified
and depicted.
But what you also see is in the
upper part of the copper plate,
you see a sequence
of what appears
to be a little thin, red
ribbon moving and twisting.
And this is the insect
in its original size.
And the undulations,
and little stars
that you might be able to see
are indicating it's movement.
The depiction of this
depiction of movement,
however, is only a
very weak reflection
of what the tiny
animal is capable of.
And of what actually Mueller--
later Mueller--
pardon-- observed.
And here I quote
again, "I will never
know for sure whether
there are comedies played
in the realm of
water beetles, even
though I saw incidence
and heroic deeds, which
would provide a basis for the
most beautiful place on stage.
The other day I
observed with pleasure
a brave polyp on the battlefield
victorious over many hundreds
enemies.
Also it is for sure that
amongst these creatures,
there is one
resembling the stage
character of the Harlequin.
His black head, his checkered
body, his ridiculous jumps,
skipping contortions, have
much in common with this funny
character of the Italian
Commedia dell'arte.
Understanding
microscopic animals move
and the theatrical
staging of the performance
of the solar microscope
went hand in hand.
And here you can see on
these two plates, how
we have to imagine the
staging, the curtains,
and the seating
of the spectators,
and the 18th century decor
of such a performance.
The theater offered a
framework to approach and make
sense of what otherwise in
the words of the art historian
James Elkins, only cost
visual desperation.
It provided the metaphors
to understand observation
by way of analogy, and
to classify phenomena
in terms of known categories.
So animate motion was indeed a
curiosity in the 18th century.
The solar microscope
brought it to the fore
as a strange and unusual object.
I will argue that it has
never quite ceased to be one.
On the contrary, animate
motion became more elusive
while had the technology
to investigate
it became more invasive.
And the scientific concept
of motion more powerful.
I have discussed this early
case from the 18th century
to give you a concrete idea
of the complexity which
the study of biological motion
had right from the onset.
The questions which
the 18th century asked,
the strategies it applied, and
the problems it encountered
are still and persist
up to the present day.
So firstly, the study
of biological motion
involved an instrument.
The microscope is the portal to
a world that is otherwise not
accessible.
Secondly, there is the
question of the representation
of movement.
With a solar microscope,
we notice a shift
from the static
representation of nature
to the performance
of the living world.
And as you have seen,
the animate quality
of the organic
world is virtually
absent in the illuminated
copperplates and engravings,
or at least it is robbed
of its powerful effect
on the observer.
Projected onto the war, the
microscopic world, by contrast,
has a frightening dynamic.
It is unpredictable and chaotic.
Along with this shift from
stasis to movement comes
the one-- and that is
important as for someone who is
historically interested--
from the well-preserved
archives of engravings, copper,
and imprinted books to
the fleeting instance
of the performance of which we
know much less today and only
actually know very little
about how these performances,
for example, looked like.
And finally, we observe
a shift in scale
with dramatic consequences
for our perception coming
with the choice
of representation.
In the darkened room, the
micro and the macro world
meet at eye level.
That is important.
The microscopic literally enters
the space of the spectator.
Thirdly and importantly,
the solar microscope
not only brought to
light a world in motion
but also a world
which could easily
be a mere illusion
and deception,
perhaps even as has been
argued, visual quackery.
After all, what did the
naturalists observe?
Their lenses unveiled an
untamed vividness and activity
in a simple drop of water.
But the phenomenon they saw,
other than flies and fleas,
were mostly not yet classifiable
in the 17th and 18th centuries.
The disarray of words
given to these phenomena--
and you have heard some of them
I think-- animalcule, dierken,
protozoa, infusoria,
uhrtischen--
they point to
fundamental questions.
Where these moving objects,
plants, or were these animals?
Were they dead or alive?
And if so, if they
were alive, were they
alive because they were moving?
Furthermore, how to describe
their many-fold ways
of moving--
as chaotic or directed?
Nuanced intention
and even like those
of the characters in the play?
Biologic motion is a phenomenon
as ubiquitous as it is elusive.
The combination of terms
even seems tautological.
Our understanding
of anything alive
is moving dates back
as far as Aristotle.
And at the end of my
talk, I'll get back
to how powerful actually this
equation of anything moving
as being alive is until today.
Furthermore, our
senses are geared
towards perceiving motion.
Our human ability to identify
movement is immediate.
It is direct, and it's
actually almost infallible.
There's wonderful psychological
research how easily
we are able to detect movement.
By contrast, any attempt to
evoke the impression of motion
outside direct observation
is dependent on some form
of media or representation.
Movement, in other
words, has to be created.
It has to be brought forth in a
particular experimental setup.
It has to be preserved,
captured, traced.
It involves some
sort of reanimation.
The conceptualization and
representation of motion
are inextricably intertwined
to such an extent--
and you might want
to bear this in mind
during the rest of the talk--
that we have to
ask actually where
the representation of life ends
and the reality of life begins.
So there is a big but to it.
If the obvious gap between
observing the world as it moves
but portraying it
as still life is
at the heart of the
scientific investigation
into movement in the
biological world,
you will ask whether the problem
vanishes quite conveniently
once scientists have new
media at hand, media which
enable to visualize
and preserve movement
as they actually observe it.
And I'm talking,
of course of film.
In film, the movement we
observe in the organism
is sort of delegated
to the machine.
And in following how
the pictures move,
we have the impression
of seeing the object move
and therefore being alive.
And it would seem that the
biological sciences concerned
with living processes
taking place
in time and the cinematographic
technique are a perfect match.
And this has indeed
been widely done.
But instead of solving the
puzzle of animate motion,
I would talk in the
following about how film made
it even much more complicated.
And I am afraid
you will experience
that to yourselves because the
amount of biological detail
and scientific minutiae that you
will have to absorb from now on
will just be increasing.
But the Swiss naturalist--
Julius Ries-- you
might have heard of him
because he is credited to have
been the very first to have
made a scientific film often
developing sea urchins in 1999
and if only his may be the
first film that survived.
And to be precise, this is not
the film, the actual material
film that survived, but
images of these film
strips that accompany
his publication.
I will not go into the
details of these films,
and these films strips,
which has been done.
Suffice it to say and
that is easy to see
that the succession
of images conveys
the impression of the
continuous division of cells
from one into to two,
four, eight, 16, and so on.
And in the case
of cell division,
Ries did not use
film to understand
the process of division.
Quite the contrary, he used
film to make maximum effect
from the camera.
He was an accomplished
histologist, well
trained in the use
of dyes and slicing
specimen and fabricating all
the tools he needed to do so--
incubators, micro needles,
nutrients, solutions, lamps,
the whole arsenal of things.
He had excessively started
sea urchin specimens long
before filming them, and he
exactly knew how they divided.
And you can see on this
plate how we've investigates
specimens, using dyes and make
these hand colored drawings
that he photographed
then to show the cell
division in this plate.
And this plate dates from one
year prior to his filming,
and it was published in a
remarkable little volume called
Contributions to
the Histophysiology
of Fertilization.
And the main subject of this
book, as the title indicates,
is not cell division,
but fertilization.
And here, in this case, Ries had
a very particular hypothesis,
and this one he wanted to prove.
He argued that, A,
the sperm does not
lose its tail once
it has penetrated
the membrane of the ovum,
which was the prevailing idea.
And I doubt that
this question appears
to be of pressing importance to
you, but it was in that time.
And B, even more
interesting, he held the idea
that it is the
tail's movement which
caused the changes
inside the egg that
occur right after
fertilization, which
are radial organization
of the substance.
So what he did is he applied the
same strategy for fertilization
as he did for the cell division.
He made maximum effect
from the camera.
In this case,
however, he used film
to create the scientific
evidence he did not have.
What did you do?
To test his hypothesis of
the rotating sperm tails,
Ries had to devise
an experiment first.
And as a skilled histologist,
he chooses a particular dye,
one that stains the membrane
and the periphery of the ovum,
because this is the area where
actually the sperm and the ovum
get into contact
with one another.
And here you can see
one of the photographs
he's made which show the
membrane and the sperm's
attaching to the membrane,
trying to cross and pierce it.
So this is a
photograph of a fixed
specimen, that is
histological preparation
of organic material.
How the sperm tails actually
rotate inside the ovum,
however, Ries neither had the
means nor the media to capture.
He could not observe
or experiment upon it.
He had no dyes to
make it visible.
And he had no
drawings, photographs,
or film to take hold of it.
Encouraged by
these obstacles, he
sought refuge in
yet another medium,
in modeling clay and paints
to make a physical model
of the ovum and the sperm.
So what you see here in
these very delicate, tiny,
white schematic drawings
is, in the succession
from left to right,
how the sperm moves
simultaneously rotating
and moving forward
towards the center of the egg.
And these are the schematic
drawings he made of this model.
This movement, he claims,
causes the radial organization,
which you can see in the
little image up there.
In his book, Ries
characterizes drawings, films,
and photographs he uses
as visual demonstrations
or sensual demonstrations.
The German word is [GERMAN],,
which is not exclusively
for images but has this
appeal to the senses--
in opposition to models,
schematic drawings,
which are explanations to him.
His scientific ingenuity,
however, comes into play
with his next idea.
He takes the best
of the two worlds
and fuses them
together into what he
names as sensual explanation.
How does a sensual explanation
of fertilization look like?
And I don't know how
well you can see it,
but it looks like a hand
drawn filmstrip or filmstrips
of the drawings
made of his model.
So what he does is he blends
film, drawings, and modeling.
The hypothesis he
could not actually
explain because he could
not make it visible
was given the scientific
evidence which only film--
and that is the supposedly
neutral observer
which is the camera lens--
could supply.
And this creation of evidence
for film is no coincidence.
As we have seen, he used the
sequential drawings-- pardon--
to represent his clay
models in his photographs.
But he chose the
filmstrip as a frame
for this particular
drawing precisely
because this pictorial
invention enabled him
to visually overcome all
the practical, empirical
experimental limitations
he had encountered
while doing his research.
And of those limits
there were many.
For example,
magnification was not high
enough due to the
lack of lenses.
Lighting was
insufficient for making
films or dyes were simply
killing the organism instead
of keeping it alive.
Or this staining just worked
in wrong parts of the organism
so that he couldn't
see anything.
And I showed you
in some detail how
Ries worked because I think
it beautifully illustrates
a historiographical approach to
the study of knowledge, which
stresses exactly the material
and the technological
conditions under which
scientific objects are
historically made
and come into being.
And the French philosopher
Gaston Bachelard condemns
this view of such a
historical epistemology
already in 1934 in a
single phrase, which I find
is a very beautiful piece
of scientific prose.
And I will quote, he says,
tell me how to find you
and I will tell
you what you want.
So in other words, visualization
techniques, media, and devices
are tightly correlated in
theorizing and experimental
tinkering and the choice of
tools to investigate motion
inside the body and
of course to convince
the spectator, too, of the truth
of the scientific findings.
Film, historians of science and
media have convincingly argued,
had many advantages in
investigating the living
organism motion and
processes in general.
Film captures an
event in its entirety
and in any detail, if
necessary, over long hours.
It never tires.
It is an impartial observer,
and it can make events visible,
which are either too
slow or too fast to be
perceived by the unaided eye.
And in addition, any kind
of biological processes
can be manipulated.
A film can be speeded up.
It can be condensed.
It can be looked at
backward, forward.
It can be stopped.
And you will agree
about this if you
have a look how the body
was primarily investigated
in the 19th and 20th century.
What you see here in
this case and in this,
which I have found in a
completely forgotten cupboard
in Berlin in the [INAUDIBLE]
are microscopic slides from
the 196--
this is from 1916--
which gives you a material
impression, actually,
how the organism under
investigation looked like.
It presented itself as a
micrometer thin dyed and dead
extract of organic substance.
Coming to my next
point, I want to argue
that bringing the organism
back to life through film
is not only a problem of
including the dimension of time
by following a process
over time or in time.
We have seen that Ries was
actually very well capable
of following the
succession of movement
by depicting it in a pictorial
sequence that is entirely
without the use of film.
As you realize, however,
when you look at these slides
is that the organism
is not only dead.
It is also flat.
It is extremely flat.
And the main reason--
this is why the details
are so interesting.
The main reason actually
why Ries could not
observe his sperm tail's
rotate in the ovum
was that the sperm's
movement was rotational.
So movements happen in time,
but they do happen in space too.
And how do you see a rotation
in an extremely flat object?
And to conquer this
space scientifically
proved a very difficult task.
Around the same time
as Ries in Switzerland,
the German embryologist
Ludwig Graper
in [INAUDIBLE] published
his inquiries into the heart
formation of birds.
In this book, he
studies the origin
of so-called blood
islands, which
give rise to the first
vessels that you can see.
If you have ever opened a
chick embryo or a chicken egg,
you can see these
delicate red network.
And as again, as marginal as
the topic might seem to you,
it is actually a very
important question
to know where these cells come
from that, in the developing
organism, form the
very first structures.
And a primary question
is, do these cells
come to the place where
the structures form
through migration that is
moving back from other places
or through multiplication, that
is, the cell division, which
is an entirely different thing.
But if movement is the
cause, where exactly
do the cells come from?
And in this case,
the question was,
it's not that important
from which of the three germ
layers that are the first
structures in the egg
they come from.
And he did so.
Like the microscopic
slide, this is a depiction
of a histological preparation.
And Graper describes
in great detail
how he applies all kinds
of acids, alcohol, dyes,
whatever to do the preparation
only to describe afterwards
how he studies motion in these
dead and fixed organisms.
And motion, it turns
out, is the measure
of the distance between the
blood islands and the germ
layers.
But not being able to come
to a definite solution,
he tentatively supposes that
the cells forming those islands
must originate from the
inner of the germ layers.
But this question still
was of interest to him.
And four years later, he
moves to the observation
of living embryos.
And now he uses
vital dyes, and I
should add a vital
piece of information
that vital dyes don't mean that
they keep the object alive.
They just postpone the
death of the embryo
for a couple of time.
But this is enough to change the
entire scientific observation
of the regime
because now Graper is
able to switch to
serial photographs
instead of using the depictions
of the histological tissue.
And this is one
of those series he
does, the series
of 16 photographs
of a particular embryo.
And he says that these
photographs, I quote,
"have the advantage to allow the
repeated comparison of images
in, not only a straight
line, but also in reverse."
That means there the
advantage of photography
is not its quality and the
precision of what it depicts,
but rather that it enables
the comparability of images
through a succession of images.
And ultimately,
such serial images
allow to condense
comparative measurements
into a line as a
substrate of movement.
And the result here,
again, is not a photograph
and it's not a depiction,
but it's a graph.
And this graph
represents movement
as a statistical phenomenon.
So what you can see here--
there are tiny, little letters
attached to the single lines
and they refer to different
parts of the embryo.
And dotted lines
are meant to qualify
whether the movements could
be sharply delineated,
and the horizontal
line is intended
to refer to the speed
of the movement.
Another 15 years later, Graper
was finally advanced enough
in his technology to register
the development of living
chick embryos on film.
So what is running here in the
background is the formation.
It's just a tiny
clip of the formation
of the primitive streaks,
which in birds is
the first major
structure to appear
in the first days of
Incubation This is made visible
with the dye nile blue
sulfate, and the process
that you can see
actually here now
has been sped up about
some 2,000 times.
And I'm showing it primarily to
give you an idea of how blurred
and to give you an
idea about the quality
of these cinematographic
material.
The cells that come together
to form the primitive streak
originated from different
parts of the ovum
and especially from
different spatial depth.
And there's some
part I won't go into,
but there is a
beautiful conception
of how these cells
forming the strains
are actually dancing and
form the dance of a polonaise
to make these figures.
But all available technology--
and you can easily see it--
did not really allow
or enable Graper
to distinguish how exactly
these movements played out
in the three dimensional
space of the ovum.
So consequently, he invented
and applied a new medium,
and that is stereo
cinematography.
Stereoscopic image--
you probably know that--
are those which
are made separately
for the left and the right eye.
And placing the images
next to another,
and if you're able to
have a cross eye look,
you're able to see a
certain spatial image.
And you can without any kind
of device, but there are also--
so if you can't
cross across, you
can use any kinds of
prisms and devices.
The stereo cinematographic
apparatus-- and this
is actually a depiction of
it-- is far more than a simple
optical device.
It is an entire
experimental system,
and it consists of
different optical lenses,
prisms, and mirrors.
It has an incubator for the
organism to be kept alive,
a heating section
for the microscope,
and various lighting devices.
The aim of stereo
cinematography was
to improve the
three dimensionality
of the representation.
And in order to
achieve this goal,
one records images for
the left and the right eye
which are not taken
at the same time,
but which are separated
by a delay of time.
This is the secret, and
how this looks like--
this image shows how that works.
So what he does is
he films an embryo
over the whole time of the
first of its development.
And this first picture,
the very first,
is taken after I think half an
hour after he started filming,
and the following images are
stereo cinematographic images,
which are taken with a
timed delay of 18 minutes,
the first one earlier
than the second.
So what stereoscopic
pictures allow
is the simultaneous observation
of successive events in time.
That means that the
movements of a cell
can be translated into space
so that the movement can
be traced-- its
cells can be traced,
and it can be
traced whether they
come from the superficial
areas of the ovum
or if they move in from parts
further deeper into the tissue.
Graper is an almost entirely
forgotten scientist today.
He devoted basically
his whole career
to the examination
of cell movement
and its role in morphogenesis.
He devised other new
experiments and devices.
He improved and
adapted them either
to fix preparations on living
animals to space and time
to photographs,
or moving images.
He did anything to
encircle and solve
the puzzle of moving cells.
Studying biological motion
is fascinating for historic
and for a historian because
it has virtually not
been studied at all.
It may be even more
fascinating, though,
because of its new presence
in contemporary biology, which
might be more familiar to you.
Movement in and of
the living world
was indeed a curiosity and
a performative spectacle
in the 18th century.
It was an object of intense
experimental tinkering,
a field of technological
innovation and testing
of pictorial forms,
media, and the rhetoric
of these representations in
the 19th and 20th century.
Over the last 50 years or so,
however, research into motion
has emerged in a variety
of biological fields--
in microbiology, with
a study of amoeba,
where the motion of
leukocytes is examined,
in embryology, as we
have seen, with a focus
on cell migration during the
process of morphogenesis,
in cancer research,
studying metastasis,
and wound healing
and regeneration
where your study
fibroblasts and how
they move inside the
body to get to the places
where they are needed.
Having been confined to
the margins of biology,
research in motion seems to be
exploding in the 21st century.
It is only two Radcliffe
public presentations ago--
and that is maybe the time unit
we have been mostly living on
in this last year--
that the Harvard Gazette
in my daily morning email
feature articles which
you may have read as well
in developments in this area.
And I want to just
see if that works.
This article on April 17 about
the interdisciplinary character
of modern biological
research cooperating
with engineers, computer
scientists, physicists,
and this article following
on April 20 to boldly go.
And what you see here in this,
I quote, in this first film,
"you see how a migrating cancer
cell trails sticky appendages
as it rolls through
a blood vessel
and attempts to squeeze
through the vessel wall."
And further down,
another example
about this research
here, I quote,
"you see how fiery orange
immune cells wriggles madly
through a zebra fish's ear
while scooping up blue sugar
particles along the way."
And another week later on--
and this very same cell
made it to the image
of the day of the
scientist as well.
And here a week
later, on April 26,
you have this
article from one many
about developmental biology.
What is this research about?
21st century biology, in
particular systems biology,
pursues new routes
of investigation
into complexity and holistic
rather than reductionist
approaches, into synthesis
rather than analysis,
into model exemplars
rather than rules--
into rules, pardon,
rather than laws.
And studying life computational
and by aggregating
huge amounts of data provides
new types of explanation
different from
those that have been
operational in the
sciences for centuries,
in particular observation,
experiment, and theory.
Operating on the level
of biological systems,
the aim of the scientific
inquiry into the living world
is also changing
towards the analysis
of the behavior of the systems
and towards the prediction
of that behavior.
In addition, perhaps the
single most revolutionary
technological
advancement to affect
the cause of 21st
century life sciences
has been life cell imaging.
Life cell imaging
enables scientists
to emerge fluorescent
labeled and marked cells
in living organisms and
study them over time
under life conditions.
And with the scientific
framework shifting
and the technology
becoming widely available,
motion finally seems to
be reaching center stage.
And to give you one last
example from the field
of developmental biology
where systems approaches
are prominent, which aim
to build what is variously
called a digital embryo
or in-vivo imaging
or the in toto representation
of development.
And the aim here is indeed
to trace every single cell
from every possible
angle in every moment
of the whole course
of development.
So this technology that is used
is called digital scanned laser
light sheet
fluorescent microscopy,
and it is as complicated
as the name suggests.
So I will only give
you a very brief idea
because I think, on the
other hand, it's fascinating.
First, you choose
a model organism,
which is usually zebrafish
or drosophila and zebrafish
because it's a
transparent organism.
And this of course you
have to keep alive.
And then in the first
step, you choose an object
of interest, which is
usually the cell, the cell
nucleus or the cell membrane,
which you have to mark
with the fluorescent marker.
And as a light
source, the microscope
doesn't use optical normal
light, but a laser beam which
optically cuts the object, the
organism in very thin image
slices using a camera,
which is detecting
the fluorescence emitted
that you previously injected.
And now the embryo is moved
slightly horizontally,
and you create over
certain intervals
ever new such of
these image slices.
And once completely sliced,
the embryo is rotated
and you do the slicing again
and you scan the embryo
entirely again.
And with this
experimental setup,
you're able to make high
resolution images that
is at the level of single
cells at high imaging speed,
and you stack the
two dimensional image
slices created by
the optical laser
together to create three
dimensional representations,
which are then finally
animated over time.
So to give you an idea, you
can see movement trajectories
of cells such as
these, and these
are the films that were released
on the Science website in 2008
about the digital
embryo project.
So we know that
development starts
with a single cell dividing
into all successful cells,
shaping the future organism
by division and movement.
And in these images,
every illuminated spot
represents a single cell.
And in this animation,
you have the animal
and the vegetative view,
which are presented next
to one another.
In another
representation, here you
have what I briefly explained.
You have the
animation is showing
how you have the images taken at
different angles, at 90 or 180
and 270 degrees.
And in another [INAUDIBLE],, you
see the movement of the cells.
And here you see how
these two representation
are animated and presented
and fused together
in a rotational representation
of the going around the embryo
so to speak.
And in a final
image I would like
to show you here is a long term
imaging of the zebrafish embryo
here of 67 hours,
which is condensed
into an animation of 44 seconds.
In these animations, we see
development taking place
in the encapsulated
space of a s sphere.
The gradual coming
into being of forms
acquires the character of an
almost ghostly apparition.
Dots appear out of
nowhere, and the eye
perceives the shaping of form
as if an invisible soap bubble
gradually fills up with action.
And it is important to know here
that it is movement alone that
brings about and drives the
formation of the embryo.
So the striking colors
which you see here
and which have been
absent in the first films
provide additional information
about the speed, for example,
of the direction of movement.
It's a color annotation
of the moving entity.
But it is important
that the movements here
define their own
space without our
being able to know exactly
what delimits this space
and whether the boundaries
are set from outside
or intrinsic to the objects.
Where there clearly
are contours,
the space inside and
outside is black.
We gaze into development
as if it were
revealed inside a crystal ball.
And indeed, the ultimate goal
of developmental projects
like these is to
construct, I quote,
"a developmental computer model
with truly predictive power."
And usually scientists
and journalists
refer to these live cell
or in-vivo visualizations
as movies.
That is the standard word used.
I think that speaking of
movies is highly problematic,
and I prefer to
talk of animation.
And your first association with
animations is clearly cartoons,
I suppose.
But a more general definition
was given by the film scholar
Tom Gunning.
And as he puts it--
and I find this
is a very useful
differentiation--
is that animations
are moving images
that have been
artificially made to move
rather than movement
automatically captured
by the devices such as
continuous motion picture
photography.
So speaking of animations
instead of films
points to the artificiality
of these images.
Just like in
cartoons, we should,
when we see such animations,
draw our attention
to the conditions
of their making.
And I have not given
you any detail of how
these animations are made.
It is sufficient maybe
to say that experimenting
upon the living body,
collecting data, and imaging
these processes as
they unfold in time
are performed in unison.
And what we see as an
event is the result
of several conversions
and translation
between the organism,
the computation,
and its visual representation.
And I find-- and I leave that--
I find the most
interesting part of it--
and I would like to
discuss this in the Q&A--
is what you actually see
here in these animations
is that you see individual
entities that are pixels
moving in these images
that are referring
to a morphological structure,
which is not the actual cell,
but the depiction of
the cell featuring
average properties, that is
statistically mathematically
gained properties.
And I find this
entirely fascinating.
But I would love to discuss
this with a biologist.
But before doing so I, want
to finally come to an end,
or rather I will
come to two endings.
And that has another reason.
So what I wanted to say before
the end is that early pioneers
in biological
cinematography, they
were convinced that the
moving images finally
unveiled the truth of life as
the camera captured movement
automatically.
Talking of computer
visualizations
as movies suggests
a continuation
of this understanding,
but is it still true
that life imaging can convince
us of the truth of life?
Eric Betzig, a pioneer
in the development
of fluorescence microscopy, who
actually in 2014 was awarded
the Nobel Prize in chemistry
for exactly this technology,
reminds us to be skeptical.
I quote, "it is often said
that seeing is believing.
But when it comes
to cell biology,
I think the more appropriate
question is when can we
believe what we see.
And when it comes to
motion, the question
actually is, what is it
that we believe we see."
And I show you in this
very first slide--
we see various
kinds of movements--
swimming, climbing,
rolling, or crawling.
And speaking of
animations reminds us
that making movement
visible is not only
displaying motion
but also playing
with the production of motion.
And indeed, what we see here
is a millimeter small highly
elastic robot whose movements
are magnetically actuated.
And you can see this, that is
research done at the Max Planck
Institute in Germany.
And you see how this really
millimeter small object is
made to move in various ways.
You can see here.
And The New York Times
reported on this research
in January of this year.
And the headline of
the article read,
this tiny robot walks,
crawls, jumps, and swims,
but it is not alive.
Playing with the production
of motion inevitably
also involves playing with
our understanding of life.
Thank you.